well President Joe Biden flew down to
Florida yesterday and met with a
republican Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
and they did a soda sort of assess the
damage and comfort people type event
after Hurricane Ian a devastated Florida
and I don't even want to deal in this
segment with Ron desantis's hypocrisy
wherein he's previously in Congress
voted against funding for disasters like
for superstorm Sandy in New York and New
Jersey and then is begging for the money
in Florida we've already talked about
that that's not new ground so I don't
want to focus on that what I want to
focus on is how either uh I mean listen
reluctantly reluctantly Ron DeSantis
praised Joe Biden and the federal
response to the hurricane indicating
they gave us everything we asked for Joe
Biden praised Ron DeSantis and even
though DeSantis had a Sour Puss on his
face the entire time
um it proves that these people can work
together and on so many issues there
really shouldn't be any disagreements
the disagreements are basically
contrived for the voters to feel as
though my guy is doing something so
anyway let's look at a couple of Clips
here here is Ron DeSantis again with a
scowl on his face and a sourpuss saying
Biden's handled this fine this general
area we were very fortunate to have good
coordination uh with uh White House and
with FEMA from the very beginning of
this we declared a state of emergency
last Friday September 23rd this wasn't
even this was a disturbance out there by
Colombia and then the next day we got a
major disaster declaration approved by
the president and we really appreciated
that and that basically set off the
massive mobilization that we had ready
to be able to respond to this storm so
thanks to Joe Biden they were able to do
everything he felt they needed to do as
of now there have been over 2500 rescues
affect you okay so there's the sent this
sort of like yeah yeah yeah it was all
good uh here is more a praise to some
degree from Ron DeSantis of Joe Biden
and and I think we've worked as well
across state local and federal of any
disaster that I've seen and so I want to
thank administrator Criswell from FEMA
for being on the ground uh being
supportive and being very responsive I
think one of the things that you're
seeing in this response we are cutting
through the bureaucracy we are cutting
through the red tape wow and that's from
the Democratic president letting you cut
through all of the bureaucracy and red
tape to get you what you need that's
pretty good local government state
government all the way up to the
president so we appreciate uh the the
team effort so there was like a really
strange feel to the entire thing
um here is President Biden also praising
DeSantis which again
fantastic I I'm these seem like genuine
genuine compliments I think it's a great
thing
so difficult to hear but Biden said he
and DeSantis have worked hand in glove
it's been great he's been dealing with
the crisis well
um and then another just really
interesting moment here was when
President Biden was praising Governor
Ron DeSantis and says one of the great
things that's happened here is we've
recognized there is such a thing called
global warming what the governor's done
is pretty remarkable so far
in terms of you know it's it's uh you
know first of all the biggest thing the
governor's done and so many others have
done they've recognized this thing
called global warming right the world is
changing yeah and descent is not
thrilled to have to sit through that for
sure and the reality is Hurricane
response is very different under Biden
than it was under Trump here is Trump
you might remember shooting paper towel
rolls like their basketballs not long
after being very confused about whether
Puerto Ricans or American citizens in
the context of one hurricane response
then he showed up and shot paper towels
like basketballs and it's all fun and
games for Donald Trump so certainly
different now here's my my big Takeaway
on this
this is a reminder
that so much of the partisanship really
is contrived now there's two
perspectives one perspective on this
would be now the partisanship is real
and both Biden and DeSantis have to kind
of turn up their noses and uh hold their
breath and sort of Praise each other
begrudgingly DeSantis is definitely
begrudging in his praise of Biden but
not because I genuinely think DeSantis
is unwilling to praise Biden it's
because he knows it's going to hurt him
with his voters if he Praises Biden too
much Biden on the other hand seems to be
having a grand old time with the fact
that hey guys listen there was a time
and and Biden was involved in politics
when it was the case where it wasn't
controversial that on something like a
Disaster Response and many other issues
even foreign policy issues in many cases
Republicans and Democrats are basically
United and worked together Biden
actually is part of that era where that
was a thing and so the takeaway for me
is so much of the nonsense that we deal
with where oh there's a pandemic well
let's all band together and just do the
oh wait you're not going to do that
you're not going to do that oh okay here
we have a foreign policy situation and
let's just all we're on the same page
that Vladimir Putin Owen we're not on
the same page a lot of it is completely
contrived at our deficit to our uh
dismay as voters and the people they
could be completely United and take out
of the political realm so much of this
stuff so very interesting to see it and
one particularly interesting moment when
Joe Biden dropped an F-bomb the David
packman shows longest running sponsor is
blinkist the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils each of them
down into an explainer you can read or
listen to in 15 minutes blinkist also
condenses episodes of popular podcasts
into 15-minute explainers I've been
using blinkist for years to supplement
the books I read I love reading I read
all the time but there's even more books
I don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com davidpakman
the link is down below